hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
haunt who are you no it's not called
that anymore it's not called the real
slender game anymore anyway I got the
back door key
so I finally found a save in the last
one we went to so I'm gonna go up here
let's see we have four of ten reports we
need to find eight before we're allowed
in the back here Slendy what are you
doing ah ah where is he elbow falls
falls where is he bird z where z rock
all right let's not lose our head here
sis keep come on what fight what the
balls what happened hey screw you
hey ho hey whoa get out of here man I
tell you he is like he's a much bigger
Duke than he usually is
alright so I need to go to plus a tiny
hill I need to go to the bunker now and
then I'll make a loop around to that
statue that should net me a couple more
pages if I don't get lost again my
flashlight is at maximum brightness
I forgot that happened at random times
so that maximum brightness
wait is that wait a minute maybe
whatever it does that it like points me
in a different direction
I would not be surprised because that
would explain a lot like every time I
got fuzzy it put me somewhere else I
would be very upset I would be very
upset
but anyway it is now officially the
darkest night ever woods okay why is it
happening more frequently get out of
here you static bastards all right so
the bunker is immediately come down
immediately this way what oh you did not
just port me oh oh you did you did you
have been you [ __ ]
yes I'm a [ __ ] where am I well you do
ah you mother oh you okay just pour me
back a bit god damn I knew something was
up I knew something was up
yesterday it was impossible that I could
have gotten that turned around I hear
him
I heard staticky chirpy okay so the
bunker is supposed to be over here
somewhere must be an entrance
hey hey hi I can't run oh this is the
worst time to not be able to run all
right so screw him pain hatred yeah yeah
yeah what a bunker I've heard that
before
Oh get the batteries oh hey hey hey hey
do not be Borton me around now there's
only a few things in here but I will
check again just to make sure nothing
was added
nice and eka we indeed all right down
here I wonder if they're gonna be a
scare waiting for me down here who do
[Music]
okay I don't know if that was thunder or
an explosion cause it doesn't matter
hi hi Oh Thunder better not trap me down
here I would be so pissed
oh I would be so pissed better or not
that he's already on thin ice I'm I've
had it up to here with slender is bit
Slenderman name's not slender slender
man or Slendy or the Slender Man for
mister man if you're feeling saucy Hey
oh come on oh come on he's in here are
you [ __ ] and a half
you bastard nugget you're ghazal
[Music]
hi we meet again looking nice Oh balls
and a half bollocks
never gonna beat this game am i I
shouldn't have done gamer apparently I'm
not gamer enough I'm too noob for this
I'm too much suck what would you do if
you wake up in place never have been
before okay so he be doing the suck in a
turd I don't know I'm bad you're doing
the suck wrong with nice okay hi alright
oh yeah gonna pop up out of nowhere
ha ha how the effing eff maybe I
shouldn't maybe I should have gone the
other way when I keep what do where am i
oh you son
bye now ha ha bollocks
Juliano I don't want to go this way
ah ah ah I guess I'm going this way now
forget the FUNKER
I'm just an [ __ ]
Marcin what how did how did I get I went
I went out I don't know I don't know I'm
on track sorry I heard that I heard that
you think I swear if somehow I got
turned around again I would be very
pissed because I have a feeling that I'm
gonna go back and somehow the house is
gonna be like on the left which should
be literally impossible because well I
left the back of the house I don't know
where I am
okay so where is this
oh is this okay good good good thank
goodness I went away from those I am
going towards the bunker
ah Joey hey ho mr. hole he who has no
face he who must not be looked upon sir
Duchenne hi Murph I like that let's go
though
damn he's like right behind me and if I
get ported back a few paces
I am boned I've been boned since I
started this game but I'm gonna be even
more fun than usual use my supervision
ultravision
hang on let me see if there's someone
ultravision right right by this penis
over here oh wait what oh yeah give me
oh oh ah I got this saves now what's up
Slendy what's that I'm the best well
thank you for agreeing with me okay now
the ultra vision is working Oh
all right so when I come out of here I'm
going to try to go straight instead of
left that left was utter doom and
straight is not utter do
[Music]
what you doing there getting out of the
leg hole in the ground
Oh God Slendy you here no thank you
I'm gonna go this way ah Sammy
typewriter saved getting the F out okay
there's no super-secret ultraviolet
messages hi hi hi hi Bob balls he's
outside put a dick
what a dick what hey oh they're dead
what a dick what a dick it's an [ __ ]
that's frickin aho
oh come on that's not fair man
not fair man did you clear out of the
front door thank you for doing that
just go on my merry way now I am NOT pro
enough for gamer mode idea what is that
what is that was that static or was that
like an engine running I couldn't tell I
couldn't tell if he was like right
behind me or what ah balls are balls are
balls
[Music]
God ah
don't jump me back don't tell me back
don't tell me back seriously do not hide
I can hear him I can feel him I feel his
presence upon me fighting or dog Bob
balls you [ __ ] Oh No do I go left or
right left or right oh god grandma
what is this oh no oh no oh no
oh no no no no my mom going through the
fields three cups of the fields straight
to the Statue and you can go fornicate
with thyself you laughing effort okay
here's another road where's this one
lead I wonder I wonder where this one
goes to oh whoa
please tell me I'm still going forward
to back oh no you are no I mean oh no I
turned to run Oh Oh bollocks
please tell me there's no wait the woods
are over there so ergo I need to go
north I hear you I hear you
you aggressive little pricks you need to
get some anger management lessons Slendy
ezel where am I we don't oh wow I don't
even know I don't know you know what I'm
gonna stop questioning how I get here
and there because obviously this stupid
son of a [ __ ] who bore me everywhere
that's kind of not fair
not making this easy on me but I am too
pro to quit now
far too Pro fart my proneness levels are
off the charts and it's gonna warp
unison oh okay
what before it does that I'm gonna
actually get kind of close to the kind
of close to the kind of close to where I
need to be maybe maybe this is this lead
I need five more notes I've got four
photos burn him in his damn building uh
don't do that don't do that to spoil ooh
Slendy man mr. mark slender actually
burned him to the ground burn him burn
him burn him like the witch she used
[Music]
ah haha yes Oh what's this on the ground
here batteries hot diggety okay so the
factory does not open yet and the hole
in the fence for the factory has been
closed and someone informed me that and
the factory will only open once I get
get down to only two scraps left which
there should be a scrap on the statue
somewhere in the woods did I get the one
off the big tree I think I got the one
off the big tree somewhere in the woods
and then in that shed so I've almost got
them if I could just just if I could
just reach my utility belt if I could
just get what I need to get and go home
[Music]
how did I get into this forest anyway I
mean come on I know people are stupid
but how stupid are you to going into
this forest looks lovely to hide from
whatever troubles might be plaguing me
nobody knows the trouble they've seen
okay right by the statue statues right
yeah where's it right yeah there's a
flip flip and - here haha
baller baller guess you won't help me
this time
but saved going sunny I haven't saved
yet you need to hold your words for me
no [ __ ] oh you [ __ ]
hey where'd you go I need to go that way
I'm not looping all the way back around
your ass ah
save me lady
save me protect him show him your boobs
stop it for a little bit
this douche this [ __ ] let me see this
guy you can see this guy's what I am
dealing with persistent oh come on
you can't do this to me over and over
and over again it's not fair my heart
can't take it you gotta let up man you
gotta just give it up okay I need to go
into the woods here cuz I know there's
something here kinda somewhere in here
it's like a path up that goes up to some
sort of like lookout post or whatever
something stupid like that and then oh
come on
do not cross poisonous plants poisonous
enough to stop me where is this thing I
don't know running in the woods now
skipping through the fields picking
flowers picking my nose picking up
chicks
picking up statue chicks and then let's
line our van pick up my trail and then
my corpse good times all around or not I
think I might be close to the lookout
post it looking rocky and I think there
might be a path up here oh yeah please
let there be a typewriter up there
please let there be a typewriter up
there oh no oh no oh no you [ __ ] oh
yeah oh no oh come on oh no oh he's
right behind he's so damn good if there
is just a typewriter up here please
please I'm begging I'm begging someone I
don't know who hi you can making me
nervous you may nervous but this is a
much longer path than I remember the
path is much longer but there it is okay
this is it all right tie rider now don't
kill me don't give a good nursing Oh
bother
I got it
got it Oh Oh can't hear you over the
sound of how awesome I am I didn't have
time to save it if I save died anyway
I'd be right by it so get away you bet
yeah brick get brick Oh actually I don't
have time
carry on so this is good thing I ran
into this save so thank you all so much
for watching keep cheering me on cuz I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna see how y'all a
man are you walked on [ __ ] you walked
over there good you are
oh he's shaking his head why is he
shaking his head
okay so thank you all so much for
watching click in Paestum for video said
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
stupid
I got a chair again bring it on I'm not
oh are you making where are you taking
everything naked Oh